Dear Miss Booksy, what's your favorite type of dog?
My favorite type of dog is a beagle.
Beagles have long and floppy ears and they have a super cute little face.
Beagles are known for baying, which is another word for making a sound,...
...kind of like a howl.
Beagles are happy and friendly dogs.
My favorite beagle is Snoopy.
You've probably seen him on TV, like at the Thanksgiving Day parade.
So kids, here are four awesome facts about beagles.
Number one.
The first breed of beagles were miniature.
They were less than nine inches high.
That's right, back in the Roman empire they were just teeny tiny guys.
Number two.
In French, the beagle means "loudmouth".
That's probably because beagles make a loud sound when they bay and howl.
But honestly, I think they sound adorable.
Number three.
They are the fifth most popular dog in the U.S.A.,...
...which means a lot of people love beagles too, just like me.
Number four.
The whole Peanuts gang comes to movie theaters on November 6.
And the Peanuts movie stars my favorite beagle - Snoopy.
I can't wait to see Snoopy and Charlie brown go on awesome adventures.
Thanks for the great question YouTuber Pumpkinpeye.